this civil war is here brother that's
right
that's right
stash your guns boys
yeehaw
we're back
the leftovers baby
what a show we have
in the 10 trillion dollar studio alex
jones is crying right now at how
spectacular
our studio got more expensive because
you know joe biden
inflation the tax lumber process
hussein pecker
i love that i'm just i'm just saying
things that like agitate conservatives
or things that conservatives are saying
you know
well you know we have so much show to
get to today it amazes me how much
content there is every week and this
isn't even like election season
oh yeah wait till trump is
announcing and ready to go he's like
kind of already teasing it i can't wait
uh i was talking to matt walsh on my on
my other podcast yesterday from not the
fascist matt walsh the good one from ucb
and veep
and uh he was saying that uh he saw
signs up and i think it was like maybe
in maine he saw signs that said 2024
donald trump the revenge tour
oh
if they're gonna kill it as a revenge
tour i don't know i mean that's like
he's ready yeah
i'm here for the revenge tour people
that's right get out your muskets fix in
bayonets boy the civil war is coming
where's your daddy uh today's episode is
sponsored by raycon we love them folks
don't we thank you thank you now first
of all we have a little bit of
controversy from last week we've got but
we'll get to that uh first thing i want
to do here today
is talk about ben shabibo
ben shapiro
basically
responding um to you making money
unacceptable
yeah he he's so right dude i was
watching this clip and i was like
this guy is such a [ __ ] liar yeah
every point he brings up against you is
[ __ ] first of all that you agree with
and addressed yeah
and he
it's just unbelievable let's just pull
it up
he was seething it was awesome dude he
was his face was all he was angry he was
like he was like mad that you know i was
like how can there be a successful
socialist broadcaster that's like only
backed by his community and not you know
millionaire donors
uh anyway you also ratio them was pretty
epic hit uh
your video got substantially more views
than his that's crazy yeah he's got like
what like four million subs too yeah i
was surprised it didn't really ban hit
off for him yeah i mean he was he was
late to the game he's failing the
culture war
yeah
that's why he's like uh
that's why he's doing tick tock react
videos now like that's what he does now
oh yeah he does them all the time and
they do well no because there's a lot of
weird cringe [ __ ] on take dog you know
no way wait i gotta look at that real
fast hold on i don't know
inside your walls ben
yeah that is so oh that's a good usage
oh yeah
um ben shapiro tick tock i didn't know
that was popping off yeah he's just been
like doing a lot of like i think he's
having a hard time juicing his content
you know what i mean they i mean they're
probably killing it on facebook i
haven't really checked their analytics
recently always but like on youtube it's
just like and not too great because like
the culture war stuff it's the algorithm
bro yeah so algo is getting crushing his
world yeah it's not good so he's got to
do whatever he can here's one that has
uh
six million views ben shapiro destroys
insane far left tick-tocker yeah yeah
it's stuff like that oh no no i didn't
mean he's on tick-tock i meant he
watches
a lot of this is the daily wire i didn't
even know that that existed oh he
watched he's watching no no he didn't
talk like react compilation i mean
that's the equivalent of crowder going
out to a college campus and owning
yeah freshmen i mean i do it too i i
love it but like i'm not above that kind
of content i'm not i wasn't billed as
the intellectual gladiator of the right
by the new york times you know what i
mean shout outs out the barry weiss so
here let's see
sexual people are asexual people who
still desire a sexual relationship but
don't experience sexual attraction
qposexual people may decide to have a
sexual relationship despite not feeling
sexual attraction while others don't
both are completely valid and
communication is key hope i could help
check out my vampire kid explains for
more it did it helped it helped i i now
understand nothing about what just
happened [ __ ] it all to work to come up
with sexual minorities now right we have
such a viciously intolerant brutal
sexist heteronormative sex patriarchal
society we have
alienated so many people that they have
to work so hard to come up with being a
member of a sexual minority that usage
like a person who didn't want to have
sex but who sometimes has sex how do you
exactly do you like identify personally
we didn't want to have sex you know that
maybe couldn't have sex that was
uncapable of like i don't know like me
in high school and in college and
basically all my adult life just
incapable of you know fighting a girl to
sleep with me i feel completely
alienated
it's just
like ben shapiro is owning a literal 14
year old yeah totally like a literal 14
year old wearing like funny unicorn
outfit on their face sometimes you're
into the section you're no longer sexual
but this is the thing it's all fluid
right you could be whatever you want at
any time and no one has to verify any of
this you just declare yourself
what are you declaring what are you
trying who verifies your sexuality what
is that okay so so so when i was 13 my
my parents verified my sexual they
weren't sure if i was a boy or a girl
and it was very normative for you know
for example my rabbi to you know
circumcise me and then suck my bleeding
penis
i didn't say any of that i can't believe
the things that he's saying here well
i'm jewish so i can say that i just i
don't even know
what that was i'm not even laughing at
it well as you know there's a practice
and even in israel they don't do it no i
should clarify i'm familiar i'm familiar
with the jokes i have jewish friends
like i i know i'm explaining for the
people oh okay yeah
but yeah there is a pr it's i don't
think they maybe they probably still do
it but even in israel i think it's
probably illegal but
traditionally when you circumcise
uh a babe this when i say tradition i'm
talking old school [ __ ]
but the uh
just takes a little sucky sucky of the
blood
and it was actually really productive
because the moyle would sometimes give
stds to the newborn baby yeah that was
good
i've heard i've heard of that
sorry trigger warning i guess yeah that
was
you know but it is what it is
i too am unfortunately
so they took something from us you know
they did
nice
that's where we're united that's what
i'm saying like there's just not a big
difference between no well you're
turkish but you're you're muslim yeah so
they they snip you yeah it's terrible i
mean there's a whole fanfare around it
too you gotta like normally in turkey i
mean i got it here
so because yeah i'm an anchor baby so i
was born here wait yeah oh you were born
here oh yeah okay you weren't like 18
yeah no no no no no that was a whole
question
no and i would have never consented are
you kidding me i'd be like [ __ ] no dude
at that age no yeah no they uh but when
you're in turkey there's like a it's
kind of like a bar mitzvah
mm-hmm is what it's called and it's like
a big ceremony and you wear like this
you know pageant dress basically you
know this big outfit and there's a whole
celebration
and they uh and they you know snip snip
and there's no blood sucking or anything
like that but we have a gnarly like old
wives tale myth thing as well where they
put it in the rice like this big pile of
rice
yeah and whoever whoever gets the the
peepee part no they they are lucky
they sure are like i don't i don't think
they do it it's just like uh themselves
are no joke bro yeah okay tell us
there's good [ __ ] in that foreskin yeah
we've
we've been everybody has some weird ass
practices that's rough that's rough oh
yeah yeah but just to make clear that
doesn't really happen uh except in you
know probably ben shapiro's uh
uh
uh temple or whatever
he's very conservative he likes
tradition i know bench bureau likes
tradition i don't even believe that he's
like a violinist from los angeles i mean
there's a lot of conservative jewish
people in los angeles though he's very
traditional
okay let's watch anyway oh so yeah oh
so this is a picture of me when i was a
coming of age and my parents said very
explicit to me that i you know i am a
male they confirmed my gender and uh you
know i was not allowed to dress up like
this
um even though i really wanted to
but um that's why i'm a beacon of
masculinity now and so when people tell
me there's 52 genders i i i just i
insist on verifying because you know
i was on a wrong path too when i was
that age this keyword is wet come take a
dive i i just don't i i will never
understand that because like a lot of
these dudes they uh try to
abide by this like super rigid
uh
standard of masculinity that they
themselves don't fit in i'm sorry but
ben shapiro
if you want to go if you want to talk
about masculine traits bro you're pretty
low on the totem yeah and it's not and
that's not like that's not a weird thing
at all but like the difference
the difference between someone like
myself and ben shapiro is literally a
living breathing proof that there is a
spectrum and it's not a binary when it
comes to gender and when it comes to
what we associate with like uh sex yeah
yeah and i mean crowder is gay so that
blasts that whole thing right yeah maybe
we don't know allegedly
all right let's watch but you know if
you've had sex with stephen crowder you
should reach out to us yeah if you've
ever smoked meth then uh if you're happy
to be a gay hooker that smoked meth and
had sex with crowd in a hotel room
please reach out we will protect your
identity yeah i would like to find we
protect our sources here on the left 100
all right off the rails but uh let's
here is uh ben shapiro reacting to
hassan making money that is a truism of
politics that hypocrisy is always
newsworthy hypocrisy is always
newsworthy if somebody is a religious
christian and then they have an affair
this is a newsworthy event according to
the media if there's a politician who's
right-wing
politician turns out to be gay really
really newsworthy according to do you
have something to tell us uh ben
what i find about that what i find
hilarious about this is that like
like
uh me
coming out as uh a a uh wealthy person
which is not even hidden but and has
never been hidden
which is part of the reason why it's
never been like newsworthy really
uh is uh
as contradictory in ben shapiro's world
as like a republican politician who's
like deeply homophobic in his policies
and like hurts gay people
uh coming out as gay like secretly being
out of this this is the tip of the
iceberg of the yeah completely missing
the point and tr and just cherry-picking
distorting and this clip is really
[ __ ] insane yeah it's great media but
there's one area of hypocrisy that is
just not newsworthy to the media like
truly not newsworthy and that of course
is if you are a socialist who's
extremely wealthy and gives very little
charity by the way this is such a niche
like how many and by the how does he
know how much money you've given to
charity he doesn't he's literally just
created this
yeah straw man this uh
this hypothetical there's so much
hypocrisy out there of socialists not
giving all their money to charity and
it's like
first of all
socialism is not charity that would make
jeff bezos the biggest socialist on the
planet if that's the case you know what
i mean right socialism is not about
charity it's literally the exact
opposite is
that in a in a perfectly
fine-tuned system where workers could uh
take more of the fruits of their labor
which bench bureau will get to in a
second
then there would be no need for charity
exactly there still exists but there
would be no need for it ultimately
because the government would provide for
you the need for charity is the uh is
the failure of government yeah 100 but
having said that i do understand in the
immediate in the situation that we're
currently living that uh charity is
unfortunately in a lot of instances a
necessity right and i do donate a lot to
mutual aid i donate to you know i i i
like to believe you but uh ben shapiro
says otherwise well the thing is like i
i don't i mean i do some of it publicly
but like not full-blown publicly like
look at me like i [ __ ] did this i'm
so sick sometimes i'll do it uh publicly
because i think it like motivates other
people like during the black lives
matter uh the black lives matter uh
protests were happening all around the
country i donated to all the bail funds
and stuff and you know urged others to
do so as well i regularly work with
other content creators who are friends
of mine to make sure that we raise funds
for you know as recently as like a
couple months back we we did a run with
jordan ewell for the baltimore homeless
uh and
they raised a bunch of money there i
think it was like 25 000.
um and i do this stuff all the time both
publicly and privately but it doesn't it
doesn't matter well yeah it's the
the funny thing is nothing hypocritical
about not at first yeah exactly
my favorite
whenever people get mad they're like
they'll pull up like open secrets
and that shows you that shows all of
your donations to
campaigns oh and they're like ah
he's only donated to bernie sanders like
you know he maxed out the bernie sanders
like what a hypocrite it's like
what am i supposed to start a pack and
like
it's bro as a singular individual like
or even with like a couple different
people like what are we supposed to is
that lobbying that's how we're gonna
that's how we're gonna win this battle
so silly it's just a bad faith argument
and he knows that like he's smart enough
to know what he's saying is [ __ ] if
you are that person then
hypocrisy just doesn't play a part
hypocrisy is never a problem because
after all you're calling for societal
change you yourself don't have to abide
by any of those rules that's right
because some animals are more equal than
other animals
but oh and uh
benefit of the bargain because you get
to be a socialist as you want to like
bernie sanders and then you get to have
a lake house you just be a millionaire
while proclaiming that billionaires i'm
paying the flesh up
nice impression whatever that was really
good but um yeah i mean again it's like
this straw man that socialists
need to they're like jesus christ give
all money away give all worldly
possessions away because you care about
poor people if you care about poor
people so much why are you wearing
clothes dude you should be wearing
[ __ ] rags like why do you have a nice
house uh like if you care about poor
people it's it's absolutely preposterous
that's a lie that that that really is
effective somehow with people well it is
because again a century of red scare
propaganda and it's really effective
it's so effective that even leftists
themselves kind of get on that train as
well
and this notion that like you can't be
successful about while being a leftist
or you can't be successful being
anti-capitalist like i find that to be a
really strange one specifically because
of the industry that i'm in it's not
like i'm in commodity production you
know what i mean i'm i'm in an industry
where it's just me
for the most part and it's entertainment
there's just there's nothing
contradictory about being wealthy
and then at the same time advocating for
laws and changes that increase your
taxes
that's it that's the thing i don't need
to vote in my interest i [ __ ]
literally vote against my financial
interest at every election so yeah
that's it
you know yeah and it's beyond voting for
me as well i mean i i believe that the
electoral system has its limitations
and um and because of that i care a lot
about like workplace organizing
democracy in the workplace these are
things that i care about and these are
issues that i not only highlight as a
part of my
job that yes happens to make me a lot of
money but like didn't really not that
long ago it wasn't like there aren't uh
you know a massive amount of leftists
out there who are super super uh
wealthy it's not a real thing
um you're probably the
richest uh prominent socialist
entertainer i mean they're just like
it's not this big category
uh that ben shapiro's making it sound
like
yeah so this issue has become relevant
over the course of the past couple of
days because a guy named hassan [ __ ]
who i believe used to be a younger turks
guy i don't really know that much about
him that's a lie by the way i [ __ ]
rationed him into oblivion a million
times like he's just like oh i don't
know who he is i don't know like i don't
know much about this guy hussein pecker
yeah
is a socialist twitch streamer
there's a big article the glowing
profile about him in new york magazine
titled streaming with hassan [ __ ] the
aoc of twitch i'm a political
commentator with like stans okay well in
the past few months
hassan [ __ ] it turns out
has been revealed to be a very wealthy
person which is good for him he has a
lot of folks who are following him over
on twitch that is his uh that is his
prerogative and i'm i'm glad for him
that he's been able to build a following
but i don't think a couple of times in
the last minute and by the way i'm like
ben you're so much [ __ ] richer than
all of us shut the [ __ ] up yeah like he
he it's like dude shut up yeah instead
hassan [ __ ] should be making his wealth
in the same way that i am by
misinforming boomers on facebook he
should be selling supplements with uh
asbestos and uh sawdust in it that cures
covet yes
and also hiring psychopaths like matt
walsh
yeah and and literally hates jews
apparently
at the last coverage not not surprising
yeah
a month it's been revealed that this
out and out socialist i mean this is
what he calls himself
that
he is um a very wealthy man quote hassan
[ __ ] was in her age a million tabs were
pinched together like sardines at the
top of his browser his jittery cursor
balanced between them summoning newswork
network news kyron's youtube brands
viral tweets and tick-tock memes the
day's trending topic [ __ ] who is 30 had
purchased a 2.7 million dollar house in
west hollywood in ordinary twitch
streamers housing wouldn't make
headlines but over the past five years
pecar has become one of the most
prominent socialist pundits in america
the controversy about the purchase had
made it to fox news and breitbart and
[ __ ] was prepared to take on the
interlopers who logged on to see the
fireworks quote the only reason my house
is expensive is because of the area i
live in he growled are you guys really
that stupid
yeah so like this is what he does
continually is takes literally one
one small passage and your huge coverage
of this story you talked extensively
about it
and tries to reduce it to like the
dumbest possible argument he can
make well it's the to be fair he is uh
white knuckling as he reads the
article
and those articles are always going to
be like you know
trying to explain what i do to a bunch
of boomers who still read magazines and
stuff so
like that's going to be reductive no
matter what and i mean i don't really
care i think the guy who wrote it was
really nice he was definitely a fan like
he was
he was well aware i mean that goes
through like an editing process so it's
whatever but
um
even then it's like it's not my fault
that the los angeles real estate market
is like abysmal and awful and it's
something that i remember whatever you
want on any property i know you can live
in wyoming and buy a three million
dollar mansion and it still doesn't
undermine your politics yeah like
my politics is not like uh people should
not have nice things yeah that's never
been that's my point is like there's no
need to even get in the weeds about like
oh la's expensive it's like you can
spend your money on whatever the [ __ ]
i'm also an avowed hedonist too like i i
believe that you know consumption is
good for
uh sedating the masses i think people
need that that's like uh
a thing that i routinely address and
criticize pre prior
experiments in socialist uh you know
transitional states so that is something
that uh like literally does not fall
outside of my my point of view that's
not something that's changed throughout
the years either like i've been
advocating for that for a very long time
um
that doesn't that's not in response to
the charge the charges that for a
socialist you seem to be spending large
my friend
that's the charge you could have there
are a lot of places that are not in west
hollywood that don't cost 2.7 again he
goes he didn't even answer the response
it's like well yeah you read a brief
excerpt of exhaustive coverage they're
all over the united states
you can get yourself a tiny little shack
and live yourself the henry david
thoreau lifestyle for probably 30 grand
somewhere
2.7 40 grand a lot of money
i don't see you handing that out to oh
he's not jesus christ bro he's a [ __ ]
dude he's immiserated workers why would
i why would he live in a shack also
where are there shacks for 40 grand and
his response is well of course it's
expensive around here this is west
hollywood which of course is not a
response that is
what's funny about this is that like
he didn't have to do the meme you know
what i mean like a lot of people try to
at least like couch their
anger in like some kind of moralistic
position
and uh some kind of like logic and
reasoning and the intellectual giant ben
shapiro here literally goes you call
yourself a socialist why don't you live
in a shack then like you didn't have to
do that you could have just you
literally did not have to say why not
live in a cave bro i mean you don't even
need to buy a shack it's pretty it's so
stupid it is this is if you're
then why don't you live in a cave and
live by uh wood fire because ultimately
that's not food for a living ultimately
that revolves around like i want you to
go away i don't want you to be
successful i don't want you to
keep you know talking to people in the
same way that you're doing i don't like
that you are demonstrably changing
people's minds and attitudes
so just go away like yeah i'll just i'll
just go live in an area where there's no
internet connection yeah you know and
people
that don't make that argument that say
like well why don't you live in a
cheaper you know house or whatever the
[ __ ] it's like well i'm comfortable like
i want to be comfortable i want everyone
to be comfortable i don't know why
people are
getting upset at that i've been living
in that same neighborhood for many years
nobody had an issue with it when i was
let me just make anything to atlanta in
a perfect social society there are still
going to be rich people right yeah
there's still thank you because that's
it this is not about
this is not about like uh
creating this weird equilibrium it's
about making sure that people
get more
and having the government absolutely
cover the basic necessities for survival
and then beyond that give people more
time to themselves so they can pursue
more fulfilling endeavors
and and all this stuff it's just it's
silly to
try to routinely move that conversation
away to these aesthetic points yeah i
just got note actually ben's so upset
he's starting a new podcast to combat
ours yeah the right wingers and uh
looks like they're about to go hog
hunting two manlets two boys these are
not short two boys
this guy
i mean yeah this guy makes ben look like
a normal height and i know ben's like
four or seven i think
yeah
quote as long as you don't defend your
core values as long as you're still
speaking truth to power then ephem yes
speaking truth to power is being the guy
who buys the three million dollar house
and does interviews with new york
magazine and then jabber's about how the
rich don't pay their fair share that's
not where i'm speaking through the power
bro if you were speaking truth to power
you would go live in a [ __ ] hut
and build bombs to be you'd be the
unabomber yeah yeah
he's like
he called yourself a socialist why
aren't you ted kaczynski
exactly what is this
yeah
oh actually speaking of ben's height and
you know i don't like first of all i
would never
uh only because he goes on about
masculinity but he is actually like five
four three so that's not real
that can't be no i think that's a real
shot right really no really no for sure
he's like four one i think
he's changing the number even he yeah
he's a very short man that's all i'm
trying to start off with like four seven
now he's another four one there's
nothing wrong with being short it's just
that he is this uh alpha male that uh i
love i love my short kings okay short
kings rule the world yes shouts out to
noel miller cody co normal oh just cody
a b
okay you don't have to name them i'm
just saying but they are kings they are
kings jabuki
like there's a there's a lot of short
kings out there who are kings all right
you know you're getting ready to round
them up dude
yeah that's my secret what was that the
that [ __ ] great randy newman song uh
short people got no reason to live
you don't know that song no
it's a satire about uh
hateful idiots but he goes short people
got no reason to live it's [ __ ]
awesome it's crazy i played i disagree
as a tall i i have to stand by my short
brethren you know as
yeah uh abe just told me ben's actual
height here is four foot exactly yeah
it's crazy i'm reading that right now
i'm not going to discord that is not
what he said
what is he going to say no for
defamation no fake news
your honor
i am clearly uh 5'3 and ethan uh
he absolutely uh uh
defamed me by saying i'm four feet now
that that that's just unacceptable spit
in my mouth
please i'm doing this in the least
exploitative way you functionally effing
can
really
he says it's my labor
i'm the one who's streaming for 10 hours
welcome to capitalism i didn't get this
point at all so that's the funny part
where he's like i got you i owned you
it's like he's saying he's basically
saying like is a man not entitled to the
sweat of his brow right
and that is hilarious because that's i
mean this is reductive
yeah but that's literally like at the
heart of marx's theory is like being
entitled to the fruits of your labor
being entitled to your value that you
create as a laborer is literally the the
opposite of of
capitalists who believe that they can
make money off of the process of
exploitation of others labor
oh it looks like we already downvoted
this by the way but damn um i just
didn't get this point uh that he thinks
it's our own it's like you clear you
don't
i just don't get it it's just weird he
thinks it's my labor
yeah yes who's labor
yeah so in other words you bet on
yourself you've done really well and you
believe that you deserve to keep the
proceeds of that labor but aren't you
exploiting all the people well he's not
you're not saying don't increase my
taxes and make social systems no i i am
an advocate for all that and beyond so i
don't
his logic it sounds smart but it's not
it's nonsense no you have to be like
fully invested in the ben shapiro verse
and his way of thinking to be like yeah
he's really spitting right now now he's
[ __ ] killing this well a lot of
people do i mean he's overwhelming
people look at him he's so pissed off
dude
yeah he's just like he i'm telling you
he's like white knuckling through he's
like huh why are they writing nice
articles about him angry people who are
engaged in commerce with you after all
what service of value are you providing
them you are twitch streaming video
games
is that a vital social service what
makes that service significantly more
important socially speaking from a
marxist perspective than the guy who
picks up the garbage why doesn't he own
a 2.7 million dollar home in west
hollywood first of all that would be
sick and also garbage people are like
the last
like here's how to touch he is because
people who work in sanitation are
heavily [ __ ] unionized yeah they do
well right and also they get paid like
out of
out of all of like the the utilities
workers like they get paid oftentimes
the most because they're unionized but
what is he
and because they provide like a really
important utility but
so does the [ __ ]
so does the guy who's packing the
groceries so does the guy who's
delivering those groceries
and
my point is literally that those people
should see more they should see more of
the profits uh back in the form of their
wages if they choose to do so or even
have a say at the very least and how
those profits are used you know what i
mean ben keeps making and this is kind
of the fallacy that i see what is he
doing he's saying socialism is
he's he's equating socialism to like
pure
equality
of income for every single person like
they're making this weird argument that
like oh you're a socialist then every
person in the world should make the same
amount of money despite
their work but that's not that's not
what socialism is it's is anything that
is the communism straight call me well
communism would be the lack of communism
would be the final stage where it's like
a
a a
a society that has is stateless
moneyless classless
um and that is
never been realized has never been
that's never happened
um it's like star trek the star trek
universe right so that's
that's entirely different uh but
regardless like some people don't even
agree with that and that's besides the
point
um
even then there is no like equal wages
there's just no wages
right right you know what i mean and
that is not somewhere not something that
we are like close to each other like
what is he doing and a lot of
conservatives do where they say well
you're a hypocrite because not every
single person does doesn't have the same
exact income and quality of life
is that an argument you're making no
i've never i've never made that argument
and also the the irony no the irony is
that the reason why i'm so successful
is not because i'm like uniquely
charismatic or anything i don't think so
i'm just a dude right
but the reason why i'm actually
successful is because i have a unique
voice in this space because of people
like bench bureau who have a baby-like
mentality on what socialism is
and they spend so much time like
vilifying it and and totally
misinforming everyone
that i think people
hear what i have to say and they go oh
that kind of [ __ ] makes sense to me
and and so thank you ben shapiro for
making me a question how much money in
your perfect society what's the most
amount of money someone can have
i have no idea what the max cap on
wealth would look like
i mean there could be yeah i feel like i
feel like it's functionally impossible
to reach a certain level of health uh
wealth sorry without
um again hiring other people and like
yeah of course severely you know
severely exploiting them or at least
like
directly taking advantage of like uh of
of exploiting people overseas at the
very least let me let me ask you a more
specific question in the case of a
company like amazon
which i think would you would agree that
amazon
has
profoundly changed society and delivers
the reason why they're success
successful because their service is so
unbelievably [ __ ] good they have
created a product that is just
it's hard to avoid because it's just so
good and there's a cost to that and the
cost of that is unfortunately the
destruction of other small businesses
which amazon in the most predatory way
predatory pricing uh way possible
eviscerates them when they take
advantage and utilize their when they
have to utilize the amazon marketplace
they go and they're like this product's
doing well we are going to make it much
cheaper we're going to deliver it much
faster we're going to lower your
placement on the search results and
basically either a buy you
buy you out you know or just drive you
out of the market
um that's what you can do when you have
functionally monopolized e-commerce in
the same way that amazon has where they
own more than 40 of e-commerce uh you
know and that's an insane number so yeah
i mean there's this one really famous
story about thediapers.com are you in
here about these diapers there was this
one seller that was crushing it on
i think it was diapers yeah yeah and
they had built this whole multi-million
dollar business through amazon
and or maybe it was diapers.com or
something and anyway amaz and what
amazon does is they uses their data
then makes the exact same product
undercuts them at a loss yeah they take
a loss to put them out of business and
then they raise the price they do this
all across the board but my question to
you is
in a perfect
social and by the way that's the
business side right that's just the
business side i brought that up and then
the other cost of that also is that like
overworked delivery drivers
overworked people inside of distribution
facilities like people pissing in
bottles [ __ ] in bags um you know
people being driven out of the company
for uh daring to unionize
um and
and all of that is invisible to us
because these are some of the most
marginalized people these are poor
people they're just trying to make a
living they're oftentimes uninformed
because society has told them like
unions are bad you know they're mobbed
up whatever the [ __ ] and also
uh you know
they they
are offering an opportunity for them
like in bessemer alabama is a great
example uh the distribution facility
offers 15 an hour there's some benefits
there too
obviously we know why amazon increased
its wages minimum wage to 15 an hour
before anyone else because they were
being bullied by bernie sanders and
progressive activists
uh to do so and now they use that as a
marketing position and if you're in
bessemer and you don't have a job 15 an
hour sounds [ __ ] awesome right
regardless you don't even think about
the time off task like how much uh how
much autonomy you have over your own
body when you're inside of one of these
distribution facilities you don't even
think about that what do you mean a time
off task time off task is when you are
not directly going the line that a
machine has set for you
inside of a distribution facility where
we use human beings basically like
robots where everything is calculated by
very well-paid mathematicians and amazon
corporate that decide what like these
routes are going to look like well or
build ai yeah to to figure out what
these like distribution routes are going
to look like that efficiency and that
delivery system comes at a massive cost
and that cost is
uh the the human labor put into it and
how much they are abused uh when you
know they
nick themselves or when they injure
themselves and and that
all of a sudden makes you an
unproductive worker so you might get
fired um it's pretty dystopian where
it's like
um unproductive worker uh drop pull open
the floor put them in the incinerator
yeah they're gonna have the boston
dynamic robots like basically
with the [ __ ] ar-15 on it being like
you know
with the 16-17 guns on the wall yeah
exactly a productive worker uh but my i
guess my question i was leading to is so
in in in a
social
socialist society
oh actually this is the they're gonna be
having these patrolling the routes here
soon if you look on your monitor there
yeah that's a machine gun mountain
boston dynamics war dog yeah it's great
i'm i'm so excited for the future that
hideo kojima literally envisioned
i mean this is like straight pmc like
hideo kojima [ __ ]
kojimbo so um
what do you do about amazon in your uh
social uh i mean i've joked about this
before but you let amazon monopolize
everything and then you nationalize
amazon with the military boom all of a
sudden no but seriously like it's even
from the ground up let's say let's say
there's a few different angles but let's
say just from the money aspect of how
profitable and how much money they make
and how they treat their workers like
what would be an ideal situation for you
to deal with a company that large but
also with a service that's become so
ingrained
well i mean we already have a massive
delivery route and a delivery system in
the form of the usps like the u.s postal
service is awesome they're not for
profit they are
literally like
written in the constitution express
especially not-for-profit because that's
what a government service that is so
valuable is supposed to do it's not
supposed to work for profit sure it's
supposed to work for the people right
and we fund it no matter what it takes
so a similar structure could absolutely
be applied to amazon workers in inside
of distribution facilities that
could uh ease some of the burden you
know give them more benefits offer them
additional benefits on top of that the
first
uh the first way to tackle this problem
before we even start talking about like
antitrust and trust busting amazon and
making sure that like the different
uh the different parts of the supply
chain that they have completely
integrated whether horizontally or uh
vertically
need to be completely separate from one
another so it's easier to manage and
control
before we even do that i think
unionization is probably the first step
so that people have a better way to
collectively organize engage in work
stoppages uh which will suck we won't
get our treats but at the very least
like you know these people won't have to
these people will be compensated fairly
they will be covered uh and
i go back to the bessemer alabama
conversation because at the time with
respect to the rest of bessemer's
economy 15 an hour seemed great for
someone who was unemployed right that's
awesome [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna do that
that's a great idea and a lot of people
joined because of that right
but what the media never really covered
and they're horrible at covering labor
issues
but what the media never covered is that
unionized distribution facilities in
that same region were making 22 dollars
an hour already and had better benefits
so
uh you know
this is not impossible this is happening
all around it happens all around the
world uh it just does not happen in
america
that's the difference so you you not you
not unionize the workers which i agree
with i mean people should be making
they should be making more money
especially with how profitable they are
but then the question is if you go back
to the inception of amazon could a
company like amazon exist in a
socialized
fully socialized government unless there
was like full-blown nationalized and
like everyone was a public uh everyone
worked for the public sector
uh no of course not i mean there are
this is why they're so do we miss out do
we miss out in a way if a company like
first of all there's ways that we can
make amazon better for society obviously
like euthanizing but are we missing out
by excluding
let's just say innovation like amazon
are we missing out as a society by
making something like that impossible
well i think that the i don't believe
that capitalism fosters innovation first
of all i i don't believe that at all and
there is plenty of there are plenty of
examples that like
the public sector has actually been the
main driver of innovation like the
[ __ ] internet you know what i mean
like these are because big
grand world changing technological
achievements uh can't be created
uh by for-profit corporations that
exclusively
want to
increase their profit margins and don't
want to make mistakes and don't want to
waste money um you have to be able to
waste funds and resources in in an
exhaustive way if you want to be able to
build world-changing tech right so
i i do think that
you know the the
profit motive gets in the way of like
truly life-changing innovation for the
most part in every sector
so i don't think we would be losing out
on anything if we were to fund more uh
you know programs like that or if we
were to even nationalize specific
sectors
um
let's say go ahead sorry well no i mean
as far as what we would be losing out on
i think what you're uh coming to what
you're pointing out is that
we would be losing out on you know
getting our treats on time in a timely
manner listen we're we're in a society
that runs on efficiency
yeah like anything and um those
differences do make a difference in
terms of productivity of the society as
a whole you know i
i think not just treats is what i'm
saying it's a more valuable service than
that the way i can reduce it to
something that you can personally see
and experience is this
you own your own
business you own your own product right
you as a content creator are your
best advocate because
you realize all of the gains
you have control over your own life you
have autonomy so you're working [ __ ]
harder than most people are right we're
in a different field because we are the
content creators ourselves so we have
wonderful people working with us
alongside us
but for the most part like
we are doing a a lion's share of the
labor right
um
my goal is to change the incentivization
structure from the negative
incentivization
of
fear of of losing your job and therefore
your health insurance and therefore your
ability to pay for shelter and your
ability to pay for food to positive
incentivization similar to what a
business owner like yourself would face
or feel you wake up in the morning
you're excited to go to work you want to
work harder than everyone else you want
to be productive because ultimately
you're being productive for yourself and
i think that that is something that we
can do that is something that we
absolutely can engage in
as long as we have more autonomy more
control over our own lives and even if
we're doing something that is not like
immediately in front of camera even if
we're doing something that is um
uh like cleaning the toilets for example
right if you understand that it's a
necessity for the workplace to function
then you have a say in the most
efficient way of doing it
and also on top of that you're being
rewarded handsomely for it okay
then you're not gonna have an issue with
like cleaning the toilets what is it it
sounds like you're saying you don't
believe in managers i mean i don't
understand that point i think management
should exist it still absolutely has to
um i think that you know there are
people who
uh
move parts around uh in a massive supply
chain and that is still a necessity the
only difference is i believe that it
would be better served
if those managers were working against a
unified force that can still be like all
right we're you know you're really
you're really [ __ ] us over right now
you're really overworking us so if you
don't give in to our demands then we
have some kind of
way of of pushing back against that some
kind of way of retaliating against that
and a good manager
will
a good manager or a good business owner
will never even
let that conversation happen because
he's already got that ground covered
you know what i mean
let me ask you a different question
let's say in this socialist society
a company like amazon using you know
public goods and not super
anti-competitive and and just doing
everything the right way
uh you create this uh society changing
it's just so [ __ ] good amazon
did everything the right way and it's so
[ __ ] good and you've got jeff bezos
at the top everybody's winning
but the guy is making so much money
because it's just so he's still going to
be a billionaire even doing everything
the right way
in that situation what do we do do we
allow jeff to be a billionaire or what
in that situation i mean that's
functionally impossible in my opinion
but in that situation no i mean if if
everyone is well it happens fine but if
everyone is well taken care of i don't
think that that that is a possibility
that's i think that's an important point
to say because a lot of people
misrepresent
socialistic values by saying that
well uh you know
you why don't you give away everything
if you're done correctly billionaires
can exist and i believe that too well i
mean i don't think billionaires can
exist i like i'm saying i'm saying
there's got to be a way because there's
enough wealth there's enough people
there's there's like 350 million people
in america
if you create a service good enough and
service that many people there's going
to be billionaires well the reason i've
talked about labor billionaires before
maybe not on the show but like lebron
james and and you know other uh
billionaires that make
really i'm talking about business owners
all of labor yeah yeah so that's the so
there's the difference there though like
billionaires can exist in that in that
way and it still says a lot about like
where wealth disparity is at this moment
and these are incredible they're they're
being paid well every all of his workers
are happy and well provided so can you
have a billion dollars
in a situation
where if every worker is still uh is is
devoid of exploitation and they have
either democratically voted on uh like
having that
uh having that distribution of profits
trickle upwards in a way where like
someone is making a billion dollars
and also on top of that there's plenty
of
um also democratically uh voted on uh uh
like excess or surplus uh revenue
generated going back to
a you know like a centralized command or
or the federal government that is then
adequately redistributed back into like
our infrastructure and our other public
sector employees and whatnot in that
situation if there's someone who still
has like a billion dollars then yeah it
doesn't really matter ultimately like
there is i want to live in a world where
there is no need to have a billionaire
you know what i mean because i i see
that as a policy failure on its face
especially the current way that our
economy is organized in the same way
that i see a single homeless person as a
policy failure like that's there's just
something that went
so wrong somewhere along the line that
like
someone could accumulate a billion
dollars and so much more in the case of
jeff bezos oh so much more yeah like it
just it it could it functionally could
or it theoretically could i don't know
if it functionally would you know what i
mean
okay but that i think it's an important
point to make that just to say like
very wealthy people can exist what every
single individual in that situation
would be making you know what i mean
like that would be or what the company
itself would be making
so
you know the in and the reason why i say
that is like it's impossible for
billionaires to exist
where there is like equal dis or not
equal but like uh
a a uh
and a decent distribution of
of surplus labor value and then also on
top of that uh a decommodification of
goods that are absolutely necessary for
survival
and also on top of that like taxes that
are going back into the government
uh to to create infrastructure like i
just don't see that ever happening it
could but i don't see it
as a possibility
yeah i don't know i think my my thing
about it is like
i think in the middle of those two
extremes of like you know
what we have now being the shitty
extreme and what you have now being like
the extreme idealistic uh
thing um
yeah you like you're you're what is
known as a as a european style social
democrat you believe that like
as long as the government is taking care
of the working class as long as the
government is like providing shelter to
those who need it and whatnot then you
know everything is good i just think
it's too i think people are just gen in
general too greedy and i think people
have this uh
it's like
a it's a biological need to keep what's
theirs right you and i do not disagree
on that at all and that's why i believe
what i believe um i i think that people
are greedy and and marx's theory
actually does not uh does not go against
that that's why i feel like a society
like that could never be achieved
because at a certain point there's gonna
be the people who do have the stuff who
do have the power and they will there's
people that will
when they feel threatened to that point
the very wealthy the very entrenched
there will always be war and that's
before that happens no you are yes and
it's called class war but what you're
describing currently
is literally the reason why ben shapiro
makes so much money and is also kind of
the reason why he's so angry right now
is that like
this system and i i fully agree with you
that's happening every day what you're
describing the class solidarity
demonstrated by billionaires
millionaires incredibly wealthy people
happens even if you don't realize it um
and we and even myself are beneficiaries
of that in the same way that
even if we want to give back more to the
government and even if we want the
government to adequately distribute
those resources to those who need it and
not to the military-industrial complex
for example um
the system is designed in a way where
it's like no you're we're gonna cut your
[ __ ] taxes yeah and there's nothing
you can do about it yeah because all the
other billionaires and millionaires they
want their taxes to be cut all the other
corporations want to take advantage of i
think like realistically
the best that we're gonna get
is in the middle a society where we have
strong social safety nets and unions and
people are well taken care of they're
still going to be uh extravagantly
wealthy people though
i think uh it's a it's a good
but way better than what we have now
absolutely but like i said before
that comes at the cost of still overseas
exploitation third world exploitation um
and not even exploitation in the marxist
sense where it's like you know your
labor surplus value being
used without your uh without your
approval or consent or say but i mean
like straight up exploitation in the
colloquial way we understand it where
it's like wage slavery like near slavery
conditions i mean
we talked about ikea like they literally
recently were like okay we can't use
child slaves anymore in our facilities
overseas like that's kind of messed up
you know what i mean and that's
that's the that's the real hidden cost
of
this entire system and like
one could easily say well you have a
laptop in front of you you're a
hypocrite like you have lap you have a
laptop in front of you there's conflict
minerals inside of that laptop lithium
batteries that were extracted from the
third world and that's absolutely valid
that's a reasonable
uh that's a reasonable thing to i guess
point out it is unreasonable to expect
someone to not use any form of
technology though which is why
socialists will say or at least those
who understand the system say uh there
is no ethical consumption under a uh
capitalist organization of the economy
it's like functionally important what
can we do about like the countries that
regulate their workers conditions i mean
like if you're in if you're exploiting
labor let's say in um
africa or uh china i mean china's i
don't know africa let's say well china
has like moved to the next step like
they did that
they threw their labor at the problem
and then they were like all right we've
improved the conditions well so now
they're outsourcing to other countries
but that's what i but also that's
another i think interesting point is
that the exploitation of chinese workers
did bring a lot of people out of poverty
and ultimately
make their conditions at this point
there is a minim there's for the most
part as i understand it like a fairly
the bottom end is a lot higher than it
used to be yeah no the the uh
eradication of poverty that every
capitalist likes to point to
almost exclusively happened in the past
like couple decades in china without
china uh being with china being removed
from those metrics
global poverty and also without changing
the metrics
so like isn't that kind of a natural
result of send exporting your labor to a
country like now let's say you go to
india we export a lot of labor to india
is the bottom line there going to
increase as all that money comes in it's
entirely dependent on how the government
uh decides to
take
the uh the the revenue how can i be and
how can i be responsible for how the
government of india conducts itself
well
america and and a lot of western
capitalists and the state department
that works in their uh interest
literally do this uh through a series of
controls that i've talked about briefly
like the imf the world bank implementing
austerity measures implementing
neoliberal restructuring in the
government and also sometimes when there
is an like any sort of revolutionary
activity or any sort of revolt against
that kind of system directly funding and
arming some of the most violent
paramilitary death squads that are
counter-revolutionary forces that end up
butchering the people in incredibly
violent ways so
like there is an interest in a lot of
these countries
uh in the people of these countries uh
to to
change the the outcome there is a desire
for it um people of iran for example
they don't want to live in a [ __ ]
brutal theocratic dictatorship they
don't want that why is there a brutal
theocratic dictatorship well because
america facilitated the overthrowing of
a government that was
democratic was socialist or at least you
know
wanted to nationalize its uh extraction
industry it's specifically its oil
refineries and that was a big no-no for
british petroleum that was a big no-no
for america and what happened as a
consequence of that an incredibly
violent brutal anti-imperialist force
that was
super fundamentalist
overtook in that in that volatility and
started controlling the country in its
entirety and has been for a very long
time and they're super [ __ ] brutal
and it sucks
like
so why did that basically i guess why
was china able to avoid that because
they don't america doesn't have that
level of influence over china america
yeah america does not have that level of
influence over china i would say that
like dengues reforms were um
were were
i mean demonstrably democratically
successful they weren't but
they did become
successful enough by
literally saying all right we're going
to throw labor power at this uh problem
uh we know that uh
capital owners will
absolutely not be able to resist
manufacturing their goods here if we
offer them such competitive wages that
it's like impossible that it's like
literally cheaper to
ship products to china and then back to
the united states right the consumption
engine of the world
um
and it worked it worked so well because
you saw jobs being shipped overseas
um
you saw the union uh the the union power
diminish and and completely eradicate
uh
in this country
and with that came worse distribution of
of profits
uh with that came less benefits or no
way to actually demand better benefits
in the workplace and that's why we have
so many problems like in comparison to
other oecd nations
and um it got to a point where it was so
successful that like do you remember the
obama documentary
the factory one
well yeah yeah
where the chinese manufacturer came back
to america to build i think it was like
glass panes or something for cars
like it it we destroyed our own domestic
manufacturing and eviscerated labor
power so thoroughly in this country that
a [ __ ] chinese manufacturer can come
back here and you know take on
additional costs in in the american
domestic manufacturing side
um
exclusively because it's good marketing
yeah that's like now chinese capital
owners can come here and be like all
right we're gonna you're gonna work for
us
and that's that's how that's how much we
have thoroughly dismantled labor power
in this country that's very interesting
and it's it's like a national security
concern if you want to think about it
from the point of view of like uh
uh in the way that like hogs think about
it you know what i mean it's just it's
terrible
well as someone i i own a business in
clothing obviously
and the manufacturing in america now for
clothing it like is non-existent where
oh i know it it's like in ch and not
only that but in china
they're
they do stuff that like you can't get
done here
and they're they're
they're great at it they're the best at
it the conditions are good and if you
try to do what you do in china here if
people think clothing is expensive
try making in america i mean like a
hoodie like this if you made it in
america first of all i just got to say i
mean i can tell you right now i i work
with
unionized domestic manufacturers
and
finding like garmin production
with those standards has been probably
the most difficult part of the process
you may not be able to and if you do the
hoodie like this is gonna run
hundreds well
right times
uh this what i'm wearing currently this
is not out yet and we haven't even like
this is not going to be the color way
for it but this is like domestically
manufactured
and um and you made there are so many
limitations you can't do color you can't
do cut and sew unique designs in the way
that you're showing right you can't do
any of that stuff well you you're
probably using a blank right yeah and
the blanks are made in china no no these
blanks are they are made here so these
are everything that i'm using is
domestically manufactured in union uh
interesting union produced
and the price point that the original uh
the company that i work with gave me was
so [ __ ] insane it was like that's no
i was not doing that they wanted to put
75 dollars on as a price point i was
like you need to lower this down to like
at least fifty four dollars because
fifty four billion
there's no way
even that's really expensive yeah
because well 54 is like what you pay for
like mass-produced blanks from china
clothing is expensive and nice clothing
is expensive yeah so
um i was like you need to figure out a
way to lower this 54 i don't care we'll
like cut out on the design side i don't
you know i want to make sure that it's
like relatively affordable
um same with t-shirts oh yeah like
they're it's incredibly costly that's
why people were [ __ ] on aoc when
when she had to tax the rich sweater and
it was 54 dollars
and everyone was like oh my god tax the
rich well you know also a fundraising
it's literally for fundraising it's
obviously but the other side of the
reason why it was 54 was because it was
union made and domestically manufactured
it's more expensive i don't have a
problem with that um i think that i
would rather i would rather do that than
you know and and unfortunately you know
not do some of the really cool [ __ ] that
i want to do
uh but make sure that it's still you
know uni manufactured and domestically
produced but it's really difficult it's
not easy it's like and well the the
problem is and also [ __ ] about like
turning profit so i have that uh i have
that opportunity to be able to do so
what you're saying the hoodie comes out
to to the msr piece being 75 or it comes
to you for 75.
no the ultimate yeah the retail cost
yeah the retail and i wonder i wonder
what's your
profit margin i have no idea yet they
haven't even shown me that yet i don't
even know what the breakdown is like so
the thing is like how we produce stuff
is so
you have to use a bunch of different
manufacturers that specialize
so like a lot of times we'll do printing
in the usa the printing in the usa is
really good
so
for some reason that's one of the things
that still works well here so we'll end
up
you know
sourcing all kinds of things from all
over the place
to get the best product but it's very
yeah but but like i'm saying the reason
why i mentioned that is because like
you would not be able to do what i'm
doing
and still
make money and like hire people and have
like
a business
um
that's the difference
like i i get that and also you would not
even be able to like experiment with
unique garment manufacturers and that
can you know take on that kind of demand
um that might change though and the
reason why i say that is because right
now we're experiencing a severe
bottleneck in our uh in our our
logistics uh i don't know if you're
aware of this right now but like there
are there's like a six line of like
[ __ ] carrier cruisers or whatever
pankerships that are sitting on the port
yeah uh right now and and that's part of
the reason why we can't get like big
items like uh delivered uh on time in a
timely manner
that's a
that's a part of the way that as a part
of
uh the reason
the reason why we have that problem
currently is because of the way that
we've designed our supply chain to be as
light as possible
and uh
small
problems like minor tweaks will lead to
gigantic issues and then we'll come back
as like inflation come back with people
not being able to get their goods uh and
a pissed off american population because
we care about consumption commodities
i'm sure more than anything else
yeah all that [ __ ] hits us really hard
all those delays and the counter to that
is
improving domestic manufacturing like
building
back our resources and our facilities to
ensure that you know we can have a va we
have a little bit like the truth is if
you want to manufacture in america it's
all like artisan boutique [ __ ] like they
don't have the mass producing
cost cut costs yeah cost cutting that
all went away and i do suspect it might
come back
because things are not looking too great
especially if you want to go to trade
war with china like donald trump did
then they have a lot more they have an
upper hand like they have yeah a
significantly better uh
advantage like significantly more
advantages in the way that they control
so much of the manufacturing and so much
of that supply chain yeah it's pretty
it's kind of it's really sad how like i
mean america used to be a manufacturing
powerhouse and uh it's just totally gone
all of that but anyway we got to thank
our sponsor and when we come back let's
get off uh
uh angry little ben shabino and move on
to
other
topics so we will be right back
time to take a short break thank you to
raycon for sponsoring this socialist
podcast i know it's crazy
it's insane is it is are we a socialist
podcast now i thought there was a
disagreement there oh yeah there's a
disagreement though
i'm not i want to go as far as tacoma
i'm i'm i like the democratic uh
socialist moniker
mm-hmm and raycon does too in fact yeah
is that are they are they saying that
that's good
dsa dsa sponsored by i'm just assuming
there's so much going on in the world
guys and it's hard to get excited about
stuff but these raycons
i love them because it's the good vibes
it's the beautiful earbuds
love raycon let me show you how it works
it's got this recharging pack you plug
them in they recharge in the pack that's
crazy it's insane technology man they
fit beautifully in the ear here's the
thing about raycon i can't even hear you
now talk
i'm saying so many terrible things we're
going to get demonetized now what i
can't hear him just said all the worst
things whether you're pumping up winding
down at work or working out recons are
my go-to
on the audio and now they've got the new
everyday earbuds that look and feel and
sound better than ever they've got this
improved rubber oil look and feel it
feels so nice in my ear it's like uh
having a nice [ __ ] your ear a little
bit you just say it's like a nice [ __ ]
my ear bro nice little [ __ ] in my ear
um you know it's optimize a perfect gel
fit right in my ear it's just beautiful
and the sound is even more impressive
than the feel they've got
settings to make sure you get the
beautiful perfect sound you want pure
mode is good for podcasts blues
instrumentals balance mode also good for
podcasts rock heavy metal it's all good
for fire well not bass mode nope bass
mode is good for hip hop edm and reggae
bass mode is good for the leftovers
podcast though
so yeah maybe in that case they're all
good for podcasts basically just listen
to our show with these okay
there's also an all new awareness modes
for when you need to be listening to
your surroundings as well and raycon
offers eight hours of play time and 32
hours of battery life there's also a
built-in mic
so you can take calls on your earbuds at
the press of a button and raycon starts
at half of the price of other premium
audio brands and they sound just as good
and i can confirm that i use my raycons
they sound bomb and it feels really good
too i recommend it the thing is raycon
comes with a 45 day happiness guarantee
so that's kind of a no-brainer wouldn't
you say it's on 45 days is a lot of days
for you to figure out if you like them
or not
well said i think right now on the left
though it is right now when the
leftovers listeners can get 15 off the
raycon order
at buy raycon.com
leftovers that's by raycon.com leftovers
to save fifteen percent on raicons buy
raycon dot com slash leftovers
all right before we get to the main
segment here there's one other video
that i feel like is absolutely essential
to watch so good oh yeah charlie kirk
aka mr potato head
um
this is kind of this guy
uh ben glib
who i is a comedian
and shout out because i have
never seen
honestly someone represent the abortion
debate so well and just [ __ ]
eviscerate yeah potato head absolutely
owned
[ __ ] destroy him just why this is
just a joy to watch so funny
it's like i love this video
you're talking about like the how it's
squished together well i mean that in
general but then his reaction is it
looks like god photoshopped his [ __ ]
face to be like goofy yeah
poor guy
i mean not poor guy well his main donor
died foster freeze and he just looks
like [ __ ] ever since his like hair is
all disheveled yeah i noticed he stopped
showering yeah he just looks he just
looks crazy lately and like he's been
getting more and more you mean the the
meat company
foster freeze what the [ __ ] foster
food oh he's a
billionaire mega donor for like the
original mega donor for turning point
you are dude i want a billionaire donor
that's his dad used to work
for
the koch brothers fun reuben too
uh yeah yeah they fund everything yeah
they fund everything dude but yeah
steven freeze uh is a uh american
investment meal yeah foster freeze fries
it's like sounds like a batman villain
yeah i mean i mean these guys aren't
literal villains so he was an american
investment manager and prominent donor
of the republican party and christian
right causes
um
and he unsuccessfully saw the republican
nomination for governor of wyoming in
the 2018 election poor guy and he lost
the primary
and uh he is like
i think his dad charlie kirk's dad used
to build like apartments for him or
something and charlie literally just
directly reached out to him and was like
yo can i have millions daddy yeah and he
was like you're a young buxom lad let's
do it i love that and now he's [ __ ]
dead dude
and he stops showering he's losing
debates it's falling apart
so watch this is the best best
best
i'm not exactly sure the other exactly
but fetuses have tails let me go back a
little bit
go ahead
embryo has tails
hey so it's a work in progress so you're
working on having kids soon
why haven't you adopted yet are you
going to adopt kids that are in need of
help pause for a second i do kind of no
it's not a work in progress bro you need
to [ __ ] to be able to have children like
yeah like tim tim pulls a work in
progress yeah he's like my dude you are
unfuckable okay you start by showering
dude it's not happening
i live a busy life but i would love to
adopt actually it's on a busy life
yeah busy life yeah he's just like he's
so busy it's just it's sad dude sad he's
just like too busy [ __ ] wearing
diapers on college campuses and [ __ ]
well you could take the keemstar method
and just start tweeting out looking for
applicants
i mean horny posting on the timeline is
charlie kirk that's dangerous
dangerous all right we have we're
we're having too much fun here let's
just watch this yeah let's have a look
charlie's going to adopt soon excellent
at eight weeks we have tails
uh at eight weeks and uh uh uh embryo
has tails do humans have tails charlie
i'm sorry what serious question do human
beings have tails
i'm not exactly sure the essence of this
do human beings have tails do you have a
tail you know i have
never met anyone with a tail i'm not
exactly sure the other exactly you know
what he's getting to you're already in
the process of being owned yeah he knows
he already knows he's being owned
charlie clark reached out to my agents
to have me on this this show i think or
whatever like his new show i think this
might be his new show i was like [ __ ] no
get the [ __ ] out of here bro yeah i love
it's called debate night and you'll see
at the end he literally ends early
because he's getting owned so hard i
love that
that's so good i'll explain that but
fetuses have tails kind of proves that
at that phase they are not a human being
they got tails humans don't have tails
we're not dinosaurs let me even show you
a photo if i may okay do you truly in
your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is a human see this
look how similar they look but
quite different dolphin you just
confirmed that a dolphin in in life do
you confuse dolphins for human babies
often he's and now he's flexing
now he's flexing he's like i [ __ ]
destroyed you the the funnier the
funnier moves like when they zoom in on
his face and he's like
like he literally you see him get like
hit in the face
with the fact the best [ __ ] moment i
mean and and also just such a great
argument and actually it's it's
confirmed that well charlie is actually
a dolphin so yeah
i understand why he would confuse the
two yeah no he can't he started as a
dolphin and he is so gummy dude that's
what i'll get that out of here
yeah nothing wrong with gun we love our
gummy kings okay i just he's not a king
so well he's not a king but we love our
gummy but
the thing is like
he now now ben here i don't know him
either but i'm i'm a fan now yeah uh
he's just he's just flexing he's like
dancing on the on the wall and he's [ __ ]
and he deserves he's doing a touchdown
but here we go watch charlie try to save
face uh and it's very small so it
doesn't have much to say but here you
can see
there you go
go ahead so let me go to sea world and
you're like someone's got human babies
in that aquarium get the human babies
out of the aquarium but you labeled it
as a human fetus no i did not
dishonestly no i did not i didn't label
it as anything let me let me feed this
one let me ask you a question though so
let's let's hold up no but you labeled
it as a human moral difference between
the dolphin and the baby
at this stage no
no you just confirmed it let me ask you
a human and a dolphin is it okay to kill
one and not the other is there a
difference morally between a human and a
dolphin i don't like to kill dolphins
but when they're like do you like to
kill babies no i don't and when they're
living
i certainly am not in favor of killing
either
okay would you abort a dolphin fetus
like yes who cares you know what i mean
yeah yeah like nobody cares
the point he's just so desperate too
he's fumbling no it was really good this
is free fall right now this was great
now i'll just say this
i am not i mean i i've debated charlie
uh twice at politicon and i've debated
plenty of other conservative
commentators some of the greatest
uh and uh i will say this i think
debates are just pseudo-intellectual
uh wrestling basically it's just like
sparring it's for entertainment it has
the capacity to change people's minds
certainly there's a 20 in the middle
that could go either way but ultimately
you're not changing anyone's minds by um
by by reasoning and like you know using
facts and logic and uh and you know the
truth comes out in the debate in the
same way that like a lot of people think
it does
um this is how you win people over to
your side by thoroughly and promptly
humiliating your opponent i was
wondering where you're going yeah
because i actually do think this is
extraordinarily
effective and it's he made a fool of him
and his argument is foolish yeah he he
destroyed him
with superior rhetoric and because he i
mean the facts are on his side certainly
unless you're having like a
philosophical conversation of what
constitutes life the facts are literally
on his side and the way that we
understand it so he
he has that
but oftentimes like if someone is like
really good at like
flipping uh flipping talking points back
you know you could still recover
charlie could not this was really
embarrassing so like he just this
man and he played he fell into the trap
so good too
you know uh if he wasn't such an
ideologue he wouldn't have fallen so
perfectly into that trap of dude
do you think for sure
in your heart that this is a baby a
human yeah
you see the you see like the the [ __ ]
the rainbow mac uh cylinder pop up in
front of his face like
like he's just like
he's like going through the talking
point tree you know what i mean no
hesitation he's just like trying to
figure out like oh [ __ ] what do i have
for this one we're off the rails i don't
know what to say yeah
do would you eat a dolphin tuna
it was like nah dude you just just take
the l you just hold it but nothing
happens
here uh it continues oh hold up the
human one sure is that not alive
no it is not alive
how is it able to have a heartbeat it's
attached to an alive being called a
woman wait so the muscle does it no it
doesn't have a true heartbeat oh yes it
does at some point it does 22 days after
conception the child's heart begins to
circulate now that's [ __ ] is also
disputed science and actually it's
literally not true eyes and eyelids nose
and mouth and tongue of form no knife it
is not a heartbeat at 22 weeks
ago what he's talking about you know how
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] is they like show
images and to be like that's a real baby
look at that you know how big that thing
is at [ __ ] at the heartbeat stage
as big as my [ __ ] like not even my
brain [ __ ] that dude that's insane okay
yeah no she's a parasite they should
they do in like texas and conservative
uh
they have like these fake abortion
clinics where they bring you in and try
to brainwash you and guilt family
planning centers they harass you
essentially yeah uh it's really really
[ __ ] up yeah and you can legally do
that yeah it's it's your life which one
is it that is not true it is becoming
pick one it's dead currently oh it's
dead it's not alive so you were once
dead you defined life dumb [ __ ]
what do you call not existing freak
anyway you're not you're like a human
that's not a human being there's not a
baby
whoa you weren't existing at one point
yeah yeah i mean you were like how old
are you charlie uh 31 okay well uh the
universe is seven billion years old so
yeah
uh the ending is here's the ending on
debate night just to kind of put a cap
on this debate night goes off the rails
i gotta watch
is that because unintended consequences
happen that you didn't anticipate we're
done debate night's over kind of like
mothers that have an unintended
pregnancy they didn't anticipate so if
you want to cut some slack for jam 6
maybe you could cut women some slack
thank you we're done
pregnant debate night's over you're the
domestic terrorist you're a domestic
peaceful protesting my friend thank you
domestic character you jinned up an
insurrection on our country debate night
went off the rails
so
see the thing that i love about
conservatives is that they're such
[ __ ] content demons that like you
know uh boo boo bennett does this all
the time too like even if they get owned
they're like ah [ __ ] it post it it's
like you didn't have to post that
brother like you got [ __ ] thoroughly
owned he has sponsors he has obligations
he's gotta post it so that's really
funny and then the other part of that of
course is that
it doesn't even matter if he gets owned
because conservatives especially ones
that like love charlie kirk they're so
[ __ ] stupid that like they don't even
think about it they're like yeah he
still he conducted himself in a good
manner well no they'll be like
[ __ ] dishonest debater of course yeah
i don't know whatever they say but
anyway i love how debate night got off
the rails and uh awesome here is charlie
kirk briefly after um the debate he has
his face gets smaller and smaller every
time he gets home
yeah yeah it's so sad all right moving
on so that's the fun stuff there's so
much stuff to get to but boy we we we uh
take our time on topics what can i say
and i like that we're we love pausing we
are well yeah together we are the paused
king nobody
okay so moving on to our main topic here
today
god hates flags
of course
look at that
not a reference to anything uh
particular that uh some uh christians
like to say yeah
so what do we know
yeah so the conservatives have been flag
obsessed
uh with the blue lives matter you know
and all this stuff um they love flags
they need their flags you know it starts
from the confederate flag here's a meme
that i've seen going around like here's
a little shot this is a good uh
tick-tock account the good liars here
just kind of give you an introduction on
their obsession with flags it's the
american flag but you pull it back and
it's the confederate flag and i actually
think that's like the most honest
flag i've seen here
at a trump rally it's the america yeah
what do you think it's like you know uh
dude you're are you
uh
are you a traitor or american i just
don't get no they're like no i'm racist
yeah that's what that says
but i'm racist you don't understand hey
here's a website
uh uh i
i american flags here you can buy it for
10 bucks disgusting oh that was
definitely made in china are they saying
that they when you pull the flag from
underneath you're a democrat is that
what that means
wait this is what the [ __ ] where was
this made this is definitely made in
china they don't show it but there's
zero percent chance that it's made in
america it was being sold for six bucks
yes
so you'll see like i think this is a
basically a revolt against
the rainbow flag
and um
other such things they
the confederate flag they just need
they want so badly to be separate
that they need to
um
they need their own flag essentially so
here's an album with some of the flags
it's just it's just so pathetic because
it's like listen listen the the the
confederate flag like you're a [ __ ]
loser like you lost dude you're that's
literally a participation trophy for a
four-year-long endeavor that ended with
a you know thorough destruction and
evisceration of everything you believe
in
and
not only that but like even robert e lee
himself in his death bed was like please
don't put up any [ __ ] monuments like
i'm we got owned bro like just don't
just don't put up monuments and then of
course the hogs were like yeah [ __ ] that
no we're gonna do that well they didn't
like the 1900s yeah and yeah exactly
they didn't even do it immediately after
there was like summer
do you know what would happen if aft
shortly after the civil war ended if
people walk around with confederate
flags they'd be [ __ ] like bro that's
like
you're trying to die yeah i mean
yeah it's not cool yeah but the
daughters of the confederacy have like
very actively been able to change public
education especially in southern states
to reflect a completely whitewashed
completely revised history that was
about states right yeah that makes it
that's the reason why you hear that all
the time yes it's right
exactly slavery bro
yeah your own slaves [ __ ] yeah
it's like yes it's just states rights
totally that's why texas didn't free uh
it's it's uh black population we need
states right to own black people
anyway here's some of the flag they've
in it they've uh inadvertently created
their own rainbow flag and dan what are
what do these stripes mean i need a i
need a key to decode this there actually
is a key in the dock but i can uh pop it
open and give you a little pop open on
the other screen
uh so they actually now they sell these
flags where each line and color means a
different thing so obviously blue lives
matter we've got one for the cops of
course can you zoom a bit i can't uh
yeah so um
starting from uh the orange line that is
for uh search and rescue uh
uh personnel search and rescue lives
matter i mean yeah they definitely had a
red line of course firefighters
firefighters getting uh the yellow line
which i'm actually rocking right here
behind me no yellow line is secure wait
yes it's security guards and tow truck
drivers tell you drive lives do matter
yeah which we mean i know they're in the
line of fire the front line the irony is
that like some of these
this all started with blue lives right
thin blue line blue lives matter which
was a counter to black lives matter of
course
uh so it's inherently reactionary
but like some of these professions are
unironically way more difficult and also
way more deadly than cops
like being a police officer in the
united states of america
uh it puts you in what like not even the
barely in the top 20 most dangerous
professions like it's actually [ __ ]
delivery driver lives matter you know or
it's landscaper lives matter
do they have a thin green line what is
that oh no it's just federal agents well
let's see uh what's the green one here
uh yeah straight just any federal agent
which we love them contributed solely to
the military force while the green line
does stand for armed services also
encompasses all federal agents during
border patrol fish and game wardens
park rangers and animal control the
control uh the color green was chosen as
many uniforms the federal agents are
shade of green absolutely uh i love that
the gray line represents correction
officers which you know hey shout out
they get their own flag why not oh no
pink
oh
that one's great for women not just all
women specifically women in emergency
services or armed services so respect
and it says all women it was originally
armed services but it's also taken on to
represent women who have breast cancer
which
okay wow it's just very inclusive yeah
it's like
if you're gonna if you're gonna
categorize this much like at least make
a separate flag dude they're like yeah
we don't give a [ __ ] about the women
again the
so here's the real flag and they've
inadvertently created a lgbtq
um flap yeah love it and by the way i
just looked it up police officer is 22nd
most dangerous job in america oh it's no
longer well it's the most it's still
very dangerous you want to know why
because they're [ __ ] getting murdered
by covid right now they are getting
absolutely destroyed thoroughly
by kobe wait what's the one right above
police
uh
number 21 is grounds maintenance workers
uh landscapers like cassandra
what the [ __ ] would you imagine though
like you know
your your landscaper is just like sorry
i have to cut your [ __ ] head off
because i'm in an incredibly dangerous
profession hold the phone what is going
on in landscaping where these
[ __ ] are getting oh dude
workplace safety is is really they're
not shooting them it's like it's just
significantly more dangerous
because they're like falling off [ __ ]
you know yeah and then what's the one
above that dan uh heavy vehicle
mechanics that makes sense to me yeah
yeah i mean it's it's mostly people that
do physically manual labor manual labor
yeah it's more significantly harder to
do those jobs and it's significantly
more dangerous to do those jobs
and uh of course they
literally get more training to do said
jobs as well right than [ __ ] cops
well let's see the what do we got here
an interesting one at number five is
garbage collectors as we were talking
about wow garbage livestream
i don't think it'll [ __ ] lie i mean
they're [ __ ]
podcasts their lives matter
that's right i mean ours is i mean hey
we take a lot of emotional strength
that's true i see my own flag yeah it's
dangerous out in these streets it's
weird i don't see podcasters on this
list so what's this one with the blue
green and red well
this is this is just the combo because
like you said they're kind of
unintentionally recreating it's like
pick your own flavor
the blue green and red is literally like
this is a pan-african flag dude
so is there any more uh dan cause we
have like the blue with the white those
are all of the colors that were listed
here i mean so anyway
i'm not kidding they literally made the
pan-african flag without realizing it
that's like something that all of those
people that were rock flags like that
would be terrified of so here's the
website which is just like smacking the
[ __ ] out oh hell yeah i want different
employees
get your veteran flags military straps
10 percent on outsourced straight from
china you can be yours for three dollars
listen the thing is like we got to
venerate these guys right anyway i
bought this hat from that website hog
hell yeah dude finally some freaking
getting them some freaking drip around
these parts man
uh here's some of the top these are some
of the toppings where this is made is
this made in front of two or no
made in bangladesh
baby supporting american workers
that's right let's go hunting brother i
love me some libs
i love that here's the top um
sales right now just to give you an idea
we don't know them all but we owe them
all
so
like oh god this is like first of all
it's so ugly like oh my god if they use
like some of the creative juices that
they have to like figure out new slurs
you know
they could make like more creative [ __ ]
at least born raising protected by god
guns guts and glory
i'll give praise to general lee i'll
love me
and a little bit of alliteration there
this is one of the top ones which she
saw this is the
lgbtq flag patriot support appreciation
correction dispatch e-m-s
you know what's funny
these are all so these are all
government jobs these people are
socialists
they love a good government job
these are all government employees like
the thing is that right that well the
other part of that problem is like we
got to do this for the military we got
to like play this song and dance all the
time i mean i have a lot of veterans in
my community they love me i have active
duty uh members of my community as well
um despite my uh you know
anti-imperialist attitude yeah well
nothing makes you hate the military more
than serving in it yeah exactly and and
the hilarity there is like we got to do
this because we [ __ ] these dudes up okay
we send them overseas even at [ __ ]
basic training they get like ptsd they
get messed up
and then their bodies are [ __ ] broken
they've sold their body to the american
government they do god knows what
overseas they're like totally [ __ ] up
in the process and then they come back
and we're like if you're really lucky or
if you're really unlucky then you get
some decent medical uh you know help
right
and and tax benefits and whatnot and
then you also get your college paid for
so you can still suffer in the same
dog [ __ ] job market with like horrible
wages with no [ __ ] labor protections
whatsoever with the rest of us but on
top of that now you have a
communications degree and you also
[ __ ] get tremors when you are trying
to piss that's serious walmart you don't
there's no infrastruc infrastructure
that can treat the trauma that these
guys go through yeah seeing friends die
seeing children and women die killing
people getting shot out getting killed
being injured i mean i have so much
respect
and i have so much sympathy for soldiers
that go and go they send them to the
meat grinder no i mean and they come
back
i reserve that for those who recognize
the the uh you know well i don't i don't
mince because in a way it's like they're
all kind of i mean
there's it's even sadder to be like uh
you know uh
uh
subservient to your slave master it's
like slave slave master
yeah but there there's
like every military member will tell you
this but like you know
hogs or members of the military [ __ ]
hate other members of the military too
like they just
you know especially liberal ones or you
know democrat ones uh so it's just like
there's a lot of there's a lot the truth
is the military's run it's a it's such a
classist uh institution because they
live and breathe on recruiting people
without better options because for the
most part if you have better options
you're not going to go the military yeah
there's two different kinds there you
have people that are like escaping
horrible conditions yeah or really
shitty conditions or people who are in
the middle class who only see this as a
way upwards like for upward social
mobility and then you have the other
side of the military which is like
military families that is like
baked into the system
and then you have the pete buddha judges
and the [ __ ] dan crenshaws who come
from like rich families mm-hmm they go
they serve at west point yeah they come
back
and uh you know they get a harvard
degree and then go and and you know
they're
people that go to officer school yeah
yeah uh for the most part dan crenshaw
still navy seal but like pete buddhist
especially like
um
so it's not entirely just like a the the
poverty draft but
i'm talking about
the people in the trenches and the front
line i mean the marines i mean
pete booty judge what did he say he was
i mean i'm assuming guys like although
then crenshaw was you know he got it you
got an injury his name is really got
purple heart yeah yeah
but like that's what i mean it's like
you literally did not you're you're the
son of a [ __ ] oil engineer born in
like scotland you know what i mean like
this dude is his dad was i mean his
dad's real suspicious dude
but i i i
i think you know hate the institution
but don't hate the uh soldiers no i
don't i don't i just i mean i do hate
the [ __ ] veterans who are like i
served so now everyone else has to get
[ __ ] over to in a similar class i'm
like how do you not recognize that like
you hate what the government has done to
you but then you're like advocating for
the government to do that to others
younger than you like how did you not
learn your [ __ ] lesson the [ __ ]
wrong with you dan crenshaw is a great
example of this right i mean he's a
piece of [ __ ] i hate him
well so leading up uh to the main point
here is that there's this movement on
tick-tock
um of people flying the black flag
which is one of the pirates exactly
that's what i thought too but no they're
they're not pirates um
they are flying it's a trumpest uh
threatening symbol saying it's basically
a threat of violence and saying we take
no prisoners uh hashtag no surrender
and here's just a little overview here
of what i love the salon.com article on
this issue because like the main photo
on the salon.com article is literally
like this dude's a juggalo
patriotic juggalo
yeah so here's the a little article
about it um yeah i mean what what's
going on there dude they love they love
larping like they just they love they're
[ __ ] nerds dude they're weebs okay
they're weebs for like nationalism
they're ready for donald trump is so
[ __ ] lame understanding the trumpet's
latest threatening symbol trump zealots
have began flying u.s flags
uh which are black which is a signal for
no quarter for enemies it's a threat of
violence and uh yeah we're gonna get
into all that so i'm gonna be honest
with you
i mean we can look at some of these tick
tocks but
i feel like a lot of stuff on tick tock
i automatically am i'm inclined to
assume is just like fake or totally over
well you tell me it's not i mean these
are real people i don't know i mean
people do it but like well here you tell
me they're not gonna do [ __ ] let's watch
oh no i agree they're not gonna do [ __ ]
i mean i'm not it's like they see others
and they're like yeah i love that i'm
gonna do it too it's like this is uh
this one she's explaining what the black
flag movement
and i think what does a black american
flag symbolize
it symbolizes no quarters
no surrender
the opposite of the white flag
it originated from the american civil
war back in
1861 to 65 he's directly from wrong yeah
was never flown in the civil war a black
american flag uh no that's also why are
you saying that you're a slaver
yeah like you're saying like i'm i'm on
the losing side there yeah well if wave
your [ __ ] black flag see what happens
okay
john brown that's what happened it means
just that the opposite of the white flag
no surrender
no
bro i'm prisoners
let me tell you something okay if you
[ __ ] got like inherited a car
dealership from your [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] father and you live in like a nice
little mcmansion in the middle of
[ __ ] minnesota okay and you're
sitting on your [ __ ] granite counter
top island in the middle of your [ __ ]
you know nice house that's like uh
growing in value okay you're not gonna
[ __ ] pick up arms and like kill your
neighbors shut the [ __ ] up these people
are
all talk and also why would you do that
for what donald trump like that's
getting him there
about this movement is that in the south
there was obvi this civil war
um gruesome deadly horrific event you
know in american history the most deadly
war by far
america's ever fought
um and they were fighting over
the institution of slavery the southern
economy was run on slavery so it was a
threat to their very existence in a way
their identity what are these people
fighting for
i don't get the conflict donald trump
like but like what's the you know
the whole thing no they're fighting for
what donald trump represents donald
trump is a really good vector for their
anger their anger for
minority populations at least having
like some kind of representation that is
ultimately meaningless by the way in the
form of like corporations just trying to
make money off of them as well even that
triggers the [ __ ] out of them you know
having a black president in a position
of power regardless of whether or not
barack obama also uh uh continued on
with america's like white supremacist
institutions and white supremacist
values doesn't matter
um that sort of stuff really triggers
the [ __ ] out of them and donald trump
was a great like [ __ ] you to all of that
so they love him they love him because
uh regardless of donald trump's like own
personal point of view regardless of
what he ended up doing in office like
you know giving more uh tax cuts for the
uh the wealthy since like the rock the
ronald reagan era like all that doesn't
matter they just they see him as their
guy who represents their values and
their values are like [ __ ] this entire
thing i think that well i think the
discontent obviously comes from
you know there's a lot of really poor
[ __ ] up white people in america too
and so they see privilege they hear
about all this privilege and white
privilege and they go well i don't have
any [ __ ] white privilege uh
you know my kids aren't going to college
and but but they misplaced the but you
know where that comes from dude that
comes from not having any sort of
[ __ ] community that comes from being
completely alienated from your labor if
you have a job that comes from not
having a a support system and the only
support system you do have the only
sense of community that you get uh is
either the church
okay and god knows what the [ __ ] your
evangelical psychopathic pastor is
saying there or
from your consumption whether it's a gun
okay but like facebook too but like
the commodities that we consume become
really important parts of our identity
because the work that we do no longer is
is even remotely interesting or says
anything about us
right if these people had access to a
good income and education they wouldn't
give a [ __ ] they wouldn't be angry
there's the other side of that too these
aren't poor people a lot of the a lot i
mean
statistically speaking
uh if you're wealthy in this country you
are more likely to vote republican than
democrat i just want to point those out
these aren't wealthy people these are
like these people these are like people
that live in a trailer no no no not all
these people not all these people i mean
that obviously exists in like places
like west virginia for example right
incredible amounts of poverty here's a
little education for you the black
american flag first appeared in the
american civil war no didn't confederate
army soldiers flew it uh to symbolize
the opposite of the white flag so
they're honoring their confederate
heritage and saying and going a step
further and saying we're gonna kill all
the yankees the irony is like the slave
owners represented a tiny fraction
of the southern population right oh but
the people that ended up dying weren't
the [ __ ] slave owners
yeah exactly so they're doing the same
[ __ ] you're doing the same [ __ ] you're
like dying for someone else's cause
slavery were super expensive i mean that
that was a huge status symbol to own it
dude it's like and these dummies are
still [ __ ] throwing their bodies at
the problem like those people who
who have like a financial interest care
about you you think mitch mcconnell
gives a [ __ ] about you dude no if he
gave a [ __ ] about you he would do
anything for kentucky okay like
literally anything except for doing all
the worst things possible to you know
destroy that state no quarter no
surrender the black fat flag meant that
the unit would not give up nor surrender
and that it was be kill or be killed oh
that girl is bad ass boy
yeah be the be the lie it gets better
i'm just trying to give a little
educational background yeah
uh here some of these people do live in
like uh horrible conditions right and
that is a factor in their radicalization
like but then they're also like the
first lady you know there's like rich
people that do this [ __ ] too and love
this [ __ ]
here let me find a really and see this
as like a way to larp as like a real
american patriot it's all it's all
symbols by the way why are people mad at
us about joking of talking about the
herman cain awards i mean when there's a
large portion of the people who are
literally fantasizing about civil war
and murdering other americans yeah
because they're the real americans
brothers here's a really good this one
is 150 000 lies they think that you know
we deserve to be murdered because we're
elitist libs and we are the reason why
uh you know they just feel shitty every
day when in fact i personally think
especially if you're not like you know
a business owner who employs like
hundreds of [ __ ] people or whatever
uh
you're like i am not your enemy okay we
have oh we're aligned i mean we're
fighting for their betterment yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] if you're like a
racist piece of [ __ ] or not like i still
think you deserve healthcare as a matter
of fact if you get healthcare you'll be
more like you'll be less likely to
continue being racist at least you'll
have like some of your material problems
access to college yeah sure
uh but here this is a big one this one
150 000 likes that so here it has
copyrighted music
uh he's this mega rapper it's [ __ ]
awesome but oh this is him no no the
music is okay this is the day i get
orders to go against the constitution i
swore to protect he's on the phone
mug down
the day i will leave lost oh i was about
to say this dude is not in the in the
military anymore
he has the veteran body like this is
literally he
i refuse to take orders against my oath
he's got a constitution on his
chest
oh [ __ ] the punisher i stand for the
constitution of my country what the [ __ ]
and i stand for the people of my country
no court of giving and the white skull
wait this dude has like a like a
what is that called like a comforter on
top of it it's like a
it's like an additional
comp yeah he has like a black flag duvet
is that what it's called oh i think and
yeah but i think that's just light on
there it does look like that yeah yeah
i love sleeping
i put my race car bed with my black flag
duvet like
this dude has almost i never seen the
top of the man bun yeah this is the
second comment you're probably a
security guard at walmart yeah this dude
is not like he's definitely a larper uh
he might have been in the military like
he may be like national guard or
something you know what i mean a lot of
dudes do that [ __ ] and then like yeah
brother this one this one's tours this
one's said with a lot of emotion and
feeling i'm curious what your take on
this one okay i love this 100 000 likes
this is this is big um
one nation one nation under god no
surrender no retreat
uh a viral video of course hashtag god
of course uh thirteen following hashtag
thirty five stars
yeah this is
some of us have had enough please watch
till the end
well i wanna hear what they're playing
like a little bit maybe i don't want the
mca but like yeah you can play it for a
bit
it's just some country music about like
yeah they all use this song yeah there
and then the maga uh rapper they usually
might switch salute the 13th fallen and
all my brothers and sisters in arms
so what i what i find funny is like
people it's like bro like [ __ ]
like a hundred afghan civilians
who were helping the um military got
blown up and some by the military oh
yeah and they were just firing yeah it
was like firing randomly at them i mean
a hundred afghans
an entire family that [ __ ] exploded
an entire family
uh of a dude who was literally a [ __ ]
uh uh like a humanitarian aid worker
who was coming back home
got blown away by a hellfire missile
strike and then they literally said he
was isis
and then they were like oops just
kidding he wasn't uh
i don't know how people can be so
callous towards them like i mean first
of all
horrible what happened to the soldiers
of course
but um
there's no
acknowled you see it in the media
there's a lot even on cnn i was watching
there's no acknowledgement
that these
[ __ ] a hundred civilians
blown up here's what's going on here's
what's going on you're [ __ ] you're 18
years old okay you sign
and uh you know you get a sweet little
camaro okay you get a nice little camaro
you you uh impregnate your high school
sweetheart who's gonna cheat on you
regularly okay here's what's here's
what's gonna happen to you are you ready
are you excited i'm gonna tell you from
all of my [ __ ] really close friends
and all the experiences that i've uh
that they've at least relayed to me okay
your high school sweetheart is cheating
on you nobody gives a [ __ ] about what
you're doing you're out in a [ __ ]
afghan empty poppy field in the middle
of like some [ __ ] valley okay dudes
with uh
way more to [ __ ] lose than you i
guess or uh way more of an interest in
like being there and know the landscape
are shooting at you crack shots from
across you don't even know where the
[ __ ] shots are being fired from you
sit down in a [ __ ] trench and you
call air support that's where you're
gonna be that's what you're gonna keep
doing for a very long time as everyone
is like is the media is not covering
your uh efforts in afghanistan nobody
gives a [ __ ] everybody's too focused on
their own [ __ ] out here and you start
slowly realizing that as the desperation
sets in okay you start getting angry
you're like what the [ __ ] why don't they
care about this [ __ ] and then one day
when you're driving over to a [ __ ]
empty poppy field that you're destined
to protect or you you're supposed to be
protecting i don't know why by the way
well that's how you fund you know jsoc
operations and cia [ __ ] overseas um
okay your [ __ ] gets blown off your your
best friend's [ __ ] dick gets blown
off by a sniper rifle okay because
that's what they're doing and nobody
gives a [ __ ] at least those 13 people
they [ __ ] died while they were
literally evacuating civilians out of
afghanistan like those dudes
those
those people gave their lives in perhaps
one of the most honorable ways that you
can go out in the [ __ ] military
uh
most of the [ __ ] casualties are like
the dude that you were training last
week
literally takes the arms that you gave
him and shoots you from behind okay like
the afghan national security forces that
you were training literally just buddy
[ __ ] you and then you're dead like
that's that's so much worse than at
least like trying to evacuate civilians
babies women children out of afghanistan
and then dying to a [ __ ] terror
attack the thing about these civilians
that nobody cares about too is like
these are civilians that the that we are
in debt to
these are yeah we [ __ ] their lives we
[ __ ] their whole lives specifically
these are ones that risked their lives
to help the military many of them
translators
stuff like that
you know that we promised amnesty to
even the regular civilians i mean yeah
but [ __ ] up but these are people we
literally promised amnesty to because
they [ __ ] risked their lives and
their families lives to be a work for
the american army knowing that if the
taliban ever came back which they did
they'd be murdered
the taliban also didn't come back the
taliban was brought back by the american
government the donald trump
administration facilitated and
negotiated that deal facilitated the uh
the release of five thousand taliban
prisoners including baradar who is like
the main taliban guy was in a [ __ ]
pakistani prison that they literally
flew out of that prison to meet with
mike pompeo so any [ __ ] this is
like oh joe bottom blah blah blah like i
can't believe this and i give a lot of
props to joe biden and i even gave a
little bit of props to a lot of props to
donald trump for even
like even broaching the subject of
evacuation and finally ending our
20-year long endeavor here in our
longest imperial conquest so far uh but
uh you know it's it's literally the way
that the american government uh
handled the situation they always knew
this was going to happen those dudes
wanted it more and we got [ __ ] owned
sorry that's just the reality no we
don't we got owned by [ __ ] rice
farmers
in vietnam always yeah dude
yeah yeah wearing flip-flops and we got
owned by dudes wearing again flip-flops
and [ __ ] dresses in afghanistan okay
that's just how it is stop pedaling with
other countries businesses like this
it's so [ __ ] stupid it doesn't matter
how much you spend on each soldier uh
the dudes with the flip-flops and
dresses will always [ __ ] he wants
more that's his [ __ ] country and
you're literally creating uh you're well
not only do we build these terror
networks directly by the way the cia did
that
also look up operation cyclone but even
jimmy carter did that against the ussr
but
we also
like we also created an environment that
was so volatile and so [ __ ]
horrifying that of course people were
like well you know i don't really
[ __ ] like the taliban but i mean god
damn it these guys are are coming in
from [ __ ] iowa and like shooting at
me and yeah blowing up my [ __ ] family
like i'm gonna fight back yeah the one
really disturbing thing i heard is that
uh this was actually even especially
under obama is because the drone strikes
were so frequent that the kids and the
families of uh in these countries
feared the clear skies yeah because the
bombs could come at any moment from a
drone strike and they felt more
comfortable during overcast because they
knew the drones were impossible to drop
i mean that is living in that perpetual
terror it absolutely [ __ ] it's
disgusting yeah um
70 or more than 60 000 civilian
casualties and the most conservative
estimations uh in both pakistan and
afghanistan uh as a consequence of
strikes american citizens were
extrajudicially killed in these drone
strikes as well uh and not only that but
uh obama only apologized when he blew up
a [ __ ] hospital in kunduz
okay and they were like my bad sorry
about that and a bunch of doctors
without borders like you know
like a french doctor an italian doctor
were [ __ ] murdered in the process i
mean we killed journalists we killed
medics indiscriminately we kill
civilians indiscriminately it is
horrifying we are a monstrous [ __ ]
nation and ultimately
the the gains of said activity don't
even come back to us they it doesn't
even come back that wouldn't justify it
by the way but it doesn't even come back
to you that soldier that goes out there
he's not benefiting from that at all
he's just a [ __ ] pawn okay you're
selling your life you're selling your
body you're selling your [ __ ] soul
and then you get nothing in return and
punk trauma yeah except lifelong trauma
and and you know maybe you'll get
[ __ ] five percent off at denny's on a
wednesday you know what i mean and then
everybody's like jerking you off like oh
thank you for your service yeah you get
it they don't give a [ __ ] nobody cares
well hold on this guy cares no he
doesn't yes he does i salute all 13.
hold on wait for it and tell me he
doesn't care that's a that's awesome
yeah that's right well this guy seems
like he's served uh he's upset he's
taking down the american flag with this
i hate that we had to do this yep
it's time
it's time girl go get the black american
flag
dude look how many flags this
[ __ ] has dude it's crazy well
it's it's all the thing is when you
endorse his trauma you have to
rationalize it right so it becomes your
idea somebody had
justified i don't know what he's making
a stand against so they're flying the
black american flag uh this is i guess
you know
uh uh uh yeah i don't know what do you
they never say what are you making a
stand against they're just angry what
they're just [ __ ] angry but he says
we have to make a stand against what
um against i don't know they don't know
what they're saying see that's the
[ __ ] funny thing people are common
ism people are like oh it's because
islam is so dangerous uniquely dangerous
like [ __ ] you're blowing up
their families and and blowing up their
infrastructure they got nothing like
they got nothing anyone and they want to
fight back against this foreign force
but then
you put up a [ __ ] black flag when you
can't get your jalopono poppers at
applebee's because there's like [ __ ]
you know uh mask mandates and vaccine
mandates i guess that's my only thing is
that i'm kind of discern is that they're
ready to go to civil war over is the
fact that the headaches the mask
mandates this top comet says bite and
say their name i i don't know i don't
know
um yeah breaks my heart we live in a
very sad world it scares the hell out of
me to see what this world would be when
my babies grow up
uh leave the red white and blue up just
put the black flag next to it we can't
get rid of the old glory that's their
plan there you go
playing right into our trap
brother millions stand by beside you we
all need to stand up at one time swords
uh
anyway there's a fetish basically
and people whipping it up the flag
they want to [ __ ] the flag they want to
[ __ ] they do actually yeah um
but people are there's actually a lot of
people whipping up the civil war thing
like tim paul is obsessed with it too
but as we go on let's see
here's another one it's just like dude i
promise you you would want free
education good shelter a meaningful life
just like everyone else does
and yeah you know you're you're not
gonna get that you're just like these i
mean see these are like relatively nice
houses that's what i'm saying this is a
nice house yeah it's not always
this notion that these are all like
[ __ ]
you know
really poor people is is not a true one
and that's like i mean are there
definitely
if you drive through poor white parts of
the country it's all bag it out
oh for sure but again
at least amongst the voter base because
the overwhelming majority of poor people
don't [ __ ] vote that's the issue okay
they don't vote because who the [ __ ] are
they gonna vote for how are they gonna
take time off work to go vote yeah so
voting is like a rich person's uh
endeavor for the most part in comparison
to the working poor in this country so
let's get that straight well here is
margarine taylor gross and got him again
uh the titan uh senator yeah attack on
congress
all right you gonna tell me that that's
working class dude real estate developer
that like inherited her business like
she's not none of these people are no i
don't think she is but they use the
working class
so uh anyway marger margarine taylor
green is uh just
a few days ago uh saying should america
get a national divorce
so
there you have it i say yes
uh 43 say yes oh no stay together that's
actually shocking i love the nine
percent undecided
yeah i'll go either way whatever that's
just that just shows like they're all
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i mean
it's all it's all fluff right this is
all like uh fantasies it's just it's
it's conservative virtue signaling well
they couldn't even do [ __ ] with like no
police wars at the capitol you kidding
me like
first of all
um the fbi now i feel like is doing
pretty much what they did to
muslims
uh under the obama and george w bush
administrations and under the trump
administration as well there i feel like
they're now doing
nearly identical things to like white uh
radicalized people you know what i mean
like
white extremists and uh you know white
separatist movements white extremist
movements anti-government uh movements
because they are responsible for the
line share of of domestic terror
incidents in this country since 9 11 i
believe more than 75 percent even higher
now probably
and they're basically [ __ ]
infiltrating groups the the same thing
happened with like gretchen whitmer
right where they were like come on you
want to do a little terror thing come on
right right come on you you want some
tannerite hey what's going on brother
you want to do some direct action you
know that's like that's just
you're a [ __ ] clown you're you're
trying to blow off steam with your
homies okay you're getting a you're a
weekend warrior you go to like a little
gathering you put a tent up you know you
train for the inevitable apocalypse and
then the fbi sends you some text
messages or uh you know an informant
sends you some text messages and rile
you up so then you say dumb [ __ ] like
yeah we are gonna kidnap the governor
you're not gonna do [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up i mean there are really serious uh
versions of this like atom often within
the american military like a nazi group
that has actually done a bunch of terror
plots that have been foiled but then you
know is i i just personally don't think
like they're going to do [ __ ]
oh i agree i mean it was all about adam
waffen i know about what atom waffen oh
that's the group that uh was swatting
yeah they were swatting me a bunch of
times and she just went to jail but
those guys are actually psychos well i
mean they that's why i said they're like
legit those are because they recruit
foreign [ __ ] i i was like oh [ __ ] these
are actually like murderous white
supremacists though yeah yeah yeah
they're kidding me they get caught with
like [ __ ] you know like explosives
and stuff regularly like they're they're
no but the fbi is pretty on them it
seems like but regardless but this is
kind of what scared me in a poll a
recent poll
52 of trump voters say they want
to separate
and then what actually really surprised
me is 41 percent of vote biden voters
said they wanted to separate
but it's all just like hogwash right
like the the actual the actual
boiling point of going to war with your
own brothers i guess these people
probably think it'd be like a cold a
cold separation a cold war you know
but like here's my question
i mean first of all a lot like
it would be over like it would be so bad
for the red states with the exception of
like texas like what the [ __ ] you got
nothing and it's funny because like even
if you go back to the civil war
you know a lot of people think it was
like a valiant war the north crushed the
south the south never had a chance of
beating the north
and um
federal government and here by the way
is um available at the same website you
can get a fleshlight the american flag
because
for true patriots only finally
the patriot the fleshlight for me yeah i
always wanted to [ __ ] a rubber [ __ ] but
you know it was just
i'm gonna come yeah but so like you know
i actually did some research they said
okay the conservatives want to make
their own country uh the red states and
we say okay
go ahead and make your own [ __ ] uh
go ahead and make the new confederacy
let's see how economically
this is going to turn out for you guys
um
this only frustrates them further by the
way when you point this out this is from
2008 the disparity is even bigger gdp 64
blue state
yeah
it's it's uh widened since then
um
you got louisiana and you got texas
those are the big like
two red states that are they got a lot
going on by the way here's medium income
from blue increasing here is the medium
income of red states decreasing by the
way these are directly this doesn't have
anything to do with like you know people
being hogs or whatever this is directly
a consequence of austerity measures
implemented in red states whether
because it's like politically uh the
right thing to do because you're like
auntie obama during the obama
administration or like you know
anti-democrat or because you're directly
in the pocket of wealthy benefactors who
stand to gain the most from uh not
paying taxes so that is the reason why
there's so much economic inequality in
these areas and that of course
radicalizes people to to a degree where
they're [ __ ] putting up black flags
outside of their houses to like
fight for god knows what here's the jobs
and blue in the blue state there would
be about uh 60 to 70 percent of tech
high paying tech jobs finance insurance
etc and in the red state you can expect
to be working in agricultural and mining
and basic manufacturing so
basically the and then i have more data
here
um
let's see here's the dependency chart so
if you look at the federal government
obviously every state pays into the
federal government
and um some states get more than others
so if we go down to the
this is really interesting return on tax
dollar okay
so at the worst return you're looking at
states like delaware okay it's at the
very bottom blue state uh for every
dollar they pay the federal government
they get 48 cents back yeah
uh they're almost entirely blue with the
ex with the exception of nebraska
delaware is the is the tax haven uh
state so right so but so go to new
jersey new jersey they get 56 cents back
for every dollar they spend if you go to
the bottom
red state north dakota
[Music]
gets four dollars back for every dollar
this country this state would be
absolutely
third world i mean it's it's literally a
carve out for uh republican uh
senate seats so right it does yeah but i
mean new mexico recently went blue uh
west virginia you've got 290 mississippi
280
um except it's it's almost
entirely done by alaska i guess they do
need a lot of federal funding because
alaska is also resource rich yeah but so
alaska is [ __ ] deep into debt
2.58 cents for every dollar they pay see
the thing is like i don't fault these
red states for taking more uh federal
funding they need it but they want to
separate they need it right they want to
separate um
yeah i mean that's why i laugh at it
here's new york new york for every
dollar they pay 70 cents get back here's
california 75 cents get back so if you
all want to go make your own new
confederacy expect to be a third world
[ __ ] country i mean they are though
but that's the so ethan that is what's
going on like
in america we live in a blue state right
we live in a wealthy part of a blue
state so
our experiences are
drastically different than someone who
lives in the appalachian mountains you
know what i mean like that guy is
literally living in
uh desolate third world conditions so
much so that like
european ngos actually come in and do
dental work uh inside of stadiums in
places like west virginia like it's
so [ __ ] horrifying yeah and these are
comparable conditions that we subject
our fellow uh american men and women to
like this is what we've done to them and
i and i i it sucks like it hurts my
[ __ ] soul when i see that where i'm
just like i want to give these people
health care i want to give these people
an opportunity i want to give these
people an industry to work in um it
doesn't matter like it doesn't have to
it it doesn't always have to be fracking
or [ __ ] coal mining it can be
anything else especially if you've been
out of a job for
a decade like you're gonna take another
job especially if it's a well-paying one
um
and it just
it sucks to see
and uh neither party is like doing
enough to address that at all
uh
and and because of that
both parties rely on a never-ending
culture war where it's like if you're
democrat you're good if you're a
republican you're good you're a patriot
you care about you know we care about
the the rights of the unborn it's like
no dude they don't give a [ __ ] these
people don't give a [ __ ] about anything
okay neither party's representatives for
the most part give a single
flying [ __ ] about you especially if
you're poor they only care about you if
you make more than 250 000 a year
that's the reality that's the
unfortunate reality and because of that
they do everything in their power to
make sure you can't even [ __ ] vote
well
you know it's just interesting how i
feel like socialism and and i mean even
even democrats
more so
than than the parties they vote for are
working so much more in their interests
and yet these hogs uh the propagandists
the think tanks the ones that don't give
a single [ __ ] about them are somehow
through the culture war have
got them blindly loyal to the point
where they're ready to go
to for a civil war putting up black
flags to fight against their own
economic interests and welfare i mean
here finally i mean they did it during
the confederacy that's what i'm saying
like they don't it wouldn't have changed
anything for them that dramatically i
mean they benefited from i guess slavery
but like ultimately they fought they
were rich people oh the rich they fought
for rich people they died for [ __ ]
rich slave owners and they're doing it
again yeah i mean that yeah they were
fighting for at yeah it's interesting
because it wasn't it was fully unmasked
then but it was also about racial it
they may have been poor but at least
they knew they were better than black
people no that's tony heasy quotes talks
about that uh has written extensively on
that subject that racial division in the
reconstruction era benefited capital
owners because it created a it created
a a a system where working-class whites
that were also in like horrible uh
poverty conditions
always at least had someone to punch
down at or someone to uh feel superior
yeah and that and that was really it was
a long way yeah that did go a long way
and it's by the way they're getting
phillips motivator it really is a final
note we're running out of time but a
final note on the civil war thing here
just to enjoy your future confederacy
overall dependency score uh red states
this is overall metric for all red
versus blue states much more dependent
on federal aid
uh much higher return on dollar
federal funding much higher and uh well
this is kind of like
covet related decline uh in state
budgets i don't know what the [ __ ] that
one means but that means that uh i think
like uh the the
coffers were emptied out in red states
because people just didn't have enough
income to pay taxes or
because a lot of the people that made so
during covid we had a what is known as a
k-shape recovery so the wealthy people
made a [ __ ] load of money like some of
these billionaires yeah like
double their worth they doubled their
net worths right whereas the working
poor specifically in the service
industry or specifically in like you
know gig economy jobs they got left
behind severely uh even if you were an
essential employee or an essential
worker like we were like oh we're gonna
celebrate you we're gonna [ __ ] you
know bust out the pans at 8 p.m like we
don't give a [ __ ] we were doing the
military treatment to those very same
people we were doing that exact same
[ __ ] where it's like
fake veneration so you shut the [ __ ] up
and you do your job but you know if you
want money nope these businesses will
not give you extra money we will not do
hazard pay we will not give you overtime
if you want that then [ __ ] off you can
[ __ ] off and die right
red states have a lot of that and then
red states have a lot of wealth
louisiana specifically is
one of the
richest
because of resources and one of the
poorest [ __ ] places in the country at
the same time interesting and the reason
for that is because it's resource dense
okay
but also there's a lot of income
inequality a lot of wealth inequality
because
there is no distribution there is no
distribution of the wealth that
literally is like right under the
[ __ ] ground and in the water like
they just don't they take all that and
they keep it at the [ __ ] tippy top
and that's precisely why when the
wealthy were making a lot of money in
places like california where there is a
you know 13 tax
when the wealthy made a lot of money the
state got a 55 billion dollar budget
surplus but in places like louisiana
even if the wealthy were making a lot of
money because uh you know the tax
structure there benefits the wealthy and
not the poor
well their states didn't actually see uh
gigantic uh uh returns on
uh in a similar capacity to like blue
states well we are at a time
uh too bad we didn't get to superman as
bisexual i know dude every time we do
this i'm like [ __ ] there's so much more
to cover i know there's so much more to
cover but we have a two hour limit on
youtube because we want them we have a
rating system youtube green lights to
make sure we don't get demonetized and
they say if it's over two hours we're
not gonna watch that [ __ ]
damn so we gotta wrap it up shout out to
the youtubers watching this then you
know
yeah the shout out to the raiders hope
you give us the green one
and uh thank you for watching everybody
this has been the leftovers going hog
wild since
2021 welcome back donald trump we can't
wait to see you
there's going to be the remember
come on now fly those black flags you
true blood americans no quarter no
quarter given
yeah
to the military and police by the way
and and don't forget the tow truck
drivers which is a more dangerous job
than police apparently oh for sure
thank you for watching everyone
[Music]